merci pour le retour pour le premier
team à jean thie alors je rappelle que
c'est un format qui n'a pas la
prétention de vous apprendre quelque
chose c'est plus pour répondre à vos
pistes de réflexion essayer de rebondir
dessus et c'est de délirer dessus ces
regards déposer le dimanche avec un
petit et et si vous êtes là pour
apprendre des choses dans ce cas là je
vous invite à la regarder mes autres
formats comme ça le sli le coup de fil
voire pop up ou à ce coup je réponds à
vos questions mais là on est plus sur un
format détente donc et pour passer un
bon moment ensemble
enfin j'espère allez petite vanne tu
fais quoi j'explique un four dans le
vaisseau qua non mais je les jeux les
imprimés en 3d on peut imprimer des
pizzas bah oui mais même ce vaisseau
mais qu on a imprimé notre vaisseau oui
mais qu attends tu imagines si on
pouvait genre tout en plus mais vraiment
tout t'imagines si ya pas encore de
gêner avec mais ça arrive s'annonce
vannes arrêtera bien bienvenue dans ce
second épisode de t'imaginer suis très
content d'être là c'est vrai ouais c'est
le plaisir [ __ ] tu perdras gaullisme
dans le ce beau dans notre beau vaisseau
deux semaines avant qu'on commence les
questions et où est-ce que genre t'es
pas chaud pour nous expliquer vite fait
et je t'aiderai sur ce que c'est une
imprimante 3d est alors une imprimante
3d et son fonctionnement en fait il est
pas hyper compliqué c'est un truc
relativement relativement simple après
c'est tout le mécanisme est justement ce
système de composites ce que tu m'aies
l'intérieur qui est un petit peu plus
délicat une imprimante 3d en gros sur
une tête d'impression qui va chauffer un
matériau qui va rentrer souvent sous la
forme de petits filaments et en fait il
va faire en sorte que que ce filament va
fondre et va déposer des couches layher
parle d'ailleurs de quelques précalc
donc pour créer une structure en trois
dimensions qu'on va passer d'un objet
modélisé sur un logiciel et on va passer
ensuite à 1
un objet physique tout cas des principes
je connais 36 points je veux dire des
des questions j'aimerais maintenant je
le tiens parlons des réponses que les
jambes raides épisode réflexion et on va
essayer de voir si on peut rebondir
dessus ça va ça va nous faire rire sont
à réfléchir ou pas partie t'imagines si
on pouvait tout imprimé vraiment
du coup on pourrait imprimer de la
bouche des meubles des vêtements et donc
les industries de l'agroalimentaire et
des produits manufacturés se casserait
la gueule donc baisse des échanges de
donc de la mondialisation ça fait bander
les altermondialistes et jsk en
alternant ds qui bandent d'un déjeuner
que dans cette navette donc c'est
évident que si on cite on a tous accès à
cette technologie qui permet d'imprimer
un a priori tout selon une autre
hypothèse il y aurait un énorme
bouleversement mais je pense pas que
tout ce que serait la gueule et j'ai pas
mal d'exemples par rapport à ça allait
notamment par rapport à la bouffe et ça
c'est intéressant ce que c'est il faut
bien imaginer que aujourd'hui d'une
technologie encore assez naissante entre
guillemets tu vois tout le monde n'a pas
ça chez soi c'est très rare d'ailleurs
d'aller chez quelqu'un qui a une
imprimante 3d un peu dur heureusement
dans la une fait de même mais bon allez
est ok aujourd'hui on peut déjà imprimé
de la nourriture alors c'est un petit
peu un petit peu comment dire c'est un
petit peu spécial mais on qu'on peut
imprimer du chocolat ça se fait très
bien d'ailleurs le chocolat c'est un
entre guillemets en aliments qui qui
marchent vachement bien que la pression
parce que ils font assez relativement
bien il ya un laboratoire qui s'appelle
candy shop 3 cdti shop scientifiquement
ce labo candy shop c'est le nom d'une
imprimante 3d qui qui est spécialisée
dans l'impression de sucre soit de jeter
comme ça et je grèce
on rentre sur terre attention perdre à
elle mais cette imprimante elle est
faite par toute une équipe spécialisée
dans l'agroalimentaire tu vois donc en
fait je pense que au delà du fait qu'il
ya des choses qui se casse la gueule en
fait il va y avoir énormément de
reconversion ok je vais je pense sommes
quand même un autre de reconversion
c'est tout ce qui est à modélisation 3d
le savoir de la 3d le savoir du design
3d etc qui est train de plus en plus
surtout aujourd'hui on a des formations
peut-être en proche de création de
logiciels hyper simple en plus d'en
avoir des vagues de plus en plus facile
et c'est déjà de plus en plus facile il
ya des logiciels qui permettent de
prendre en photo quelque chose
trop d envoi est le logiciel avec du
type learning il te re créer l'objet tu
vois donc en fait il va y avoir photo
plusieurs angles voix il faut plus rien
pour l'instant
il ya même des trucs complètement
incroyable mais ça c'est fou et ça ça va
arriver dans quelques années tu prends
une feuille tu dessines un cube et par
philippe le sort en est le sort en
fichiers stl que tu va balancer
attendant présente à ce bas cc je suis
passé du type learning mais p la
perspective en perspective
c'est ça et on comprend que c'est un
cube c'est ça donc c'est ça défonce j'ai
pris un lien je mettrai en déception de
l'ariège
ça va ça va certainement basculer mais
ce je pense faire basculer dans le bon
sens jusqu'à se trouver une stabilité
intéressante attention au joystick de
contrôle de la navette soient pas toutes
parts sur sur la planète look de plus si
on pouvait imprimer tout ce qui est
matériel à par des humains on se
lasserait vite de tous les désirs
matériels et on aurait donc des désirs
plus en rapport avec autrui
on vivrait donc plus dans l'instant à
essayer de partager ce qu'on ce que l'on
a
je sais pas si vraiment on vivrait plus
l'instant présent ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'on aurait d'autres types de désir en
fait il ya un truc aussi qu'il faut pas
négliger mais ça je pense que tant qu'on
n'a pas imprimé cette rue qu'on peut pas
le ressentir c'est que quand on a quand
on va à la fnac et qu'on achète un
appareil photo ouais ça nous procure un
plaisir on est content on a les
satisfait parce qu'on a comblé un désir
quoi le truc c'est que quand on aime
quelque chose un manque comme besoin
quand après cette action est c'est ça
ouais quelque chose c'est ben c'est un
petit peu la même chose en fait mais
encore pire parce que c'est toi qui l'a
fait ouais et en plus tu vois le
processus de vente 3 de création quoi et
le truc c'est que imprimés quelque chose
en tout cas maintenant ça se fait pas
comme ça tu vois ça prend du temps
ouais donc imprimer un appareil de photo
ça va prendre énormément de temps ça va
prendre fin j'imagine bien est-ce que
c'est pas parce que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui dans le sens où c'est un
truc nouveau pour nous et donc c'est
pour ça que cette fraction est décuplée
mais imagine si on faisait ça tout le
temps est ce que on n'aurait pas une
satisfaction moindre parce qu'on serait
habitués suis sûrement mais le truc
c'est qu'on imprimerait pas toutes les
semaines un appareil photo par exemple
on apprendrait tout en y trouve des
choses différemment mais du coup
peut-être que si on fait peut-être ça a
complètement changé nous habitent nos
habitudes de consommation
peut-être que vous
être beaucoup plus de temps le jetable
tu as maintenant peut-être qu'en fait tu
vois aujourd'hui moi je change pas ma
caméra
même si des fois là des
dysfonctionnements si j'avais à imprimer
la pièce pour la réparer soi-même et je
vais plus loin dans ce cas là autant un
premier cash l'appareil tu vois donc pas
pourquoi pourquoi tu passerais pas juste
cinq minutes à réparer la imprimer la
pièce que tu connais les hommes c'est
qu'on en ait fait sûrs mais si je n'en
ai si je peux avoir un truc qui défonce
je vais faire sur et s'ils s'imaginent
trois mois plus tard cannon sans un
autre modèle 3d imprimés qui est encore
plus fort ben je verrais imprimé au bout
de trois mois je suis d'accord je pense
que le cycle de vie des produits en fait
va être beaucoup plus éphémère quoi
beaucoup plus courts ce genre de
marketing là ils existent déjà mais pas
avec des produits électroniques
technologies et des constructeurs fin
des créateurs des designers qui qui sont
dans le business par exemple du casse
tête et qui mois après mois balance des
améliorations de leur caste est un prime
chez toi on pourrait donc imprimer des
organes genre plus besoin d'attendre
pour une greffe
on pourrait se créer un nouveau coeur ou
estomac par exemple tu peux aussi
agrandir le pénis étaient en vie accès à
la vie éternelle l'humain deviendrai
réparable c'est ce que tu invites
agrandir le pénis et ben écoute j'en ai
pas du tout besoin
j'ai un pénis énorme et je suis
vachement content mon pénis
ok aujourd'hui on peut déjà imprimé du
tissu humain oui des organes willie mays
imprimée du plastique est imprimée du
tissu humain c'est pas du tout le même
procédé mais c'est beaucoup plus
complexe comme tu peux l'imaginer
imprimée du pyla ou de la baisse et de
différents types de plastiques on peut
plus ou moins le faire tous chez nous
déjà privé de la baisse il faut une
voiture enfin c'est voilà et du pl a il
faut du d'une voiture où dieu pour faire
des plâtres voilà mes livres à des vents
plus forts que moi mais les zoos place
assez haut
une veine préfet sur l'ancien t'imagines
si d'accord vous j'avais jamais le
réflexe plat euh je l'avais imprimée du
tissu humain aujourd'hui comment on fait
alors je suis pas certains jugent pas
non plus un spécialiste dans le domaine
en gros on prend un gel qui contient des
cellules souches et on prend un polymère
biodégradable
donc on les mix entre les ensembles et
donc on va imprimer encore une fois en
3d successivement des couches et donc à
mesure en fait que les cellules souches
se développe dans le produit en question
pendant ce qu'on imprime et bien le
polymère ce2 se dégradent disparaître tu
vois comme ça il ya un cycle
qui fait que l'organe le cartilage ou
quoi se développe correctement
aujourd'hui pour ce qui est d'imprimer
du tissu humain on le fait vraiment à
l'échelle microscopique et souvent les
grèves se passe pas bien encore mais en
revanche c'est à dire qui dérogeait du
coup quoi en revanche dans le futur je
suis fou qu'il arrive à le faire sans
registre sur des sous sur des souris il
arrive à faire des vrais greffe en tout
cas sûr à cette imprimante qui est
capable de tout imprimé oui elle pourra
imprimer des organes et moi j'ai envie
d'aller plus loin dans une logique
transhumanistes on pourrait même un
imprimé des organes qui sont meilleurs
que les organes qu'on a actuellement on
pouvait entraîner parmi un projet qui
s'appelle haye qui est prévu pour 2027
je crois en gros c'est un oeil bionique
donc imprimé en 3d qui te permet d'avoir
une vision beaucoup plus forte que ce
que tu as et quittant même permis
d'avoir des filtres genre des filtres
romanista g tu vois de ce que tu vois et
c'est que tu pour activer/désactiver
clark imagine tu es constamment buggé
sur le filtre faced wap un [ __ ]
l'enfer tu imagines si on avait tous une
imprimante 3d qui leur étaient toutes
imprimées
il y avait une imprimante 3d de ce type
tout le monde qu'on serait bien plus de
bien qu'aujourd'hui donc nécessité de
trouver d'autres ressources matérielles
énergétique de plus les gens qui ont
trouvé leur vie d'un ennui monstre car
chacun de leurs désirs pour être
satisfait sans avoir assez souffert
pourrait prendre du plaisir
cela pousserait les gens à la perversion
qu'elle chercherait de nouveaux désirs à
combler de plus en plus extrêmes cela
aboutirait sur un génocide donc
quelqu'un qui veut être un raccourci
mario kart rock ou bien une guerre car
les hommes ont plus de temps à perdre
sachant que chacun pourra se procurer
une bombe atomique dernière génération
je donne trois semaines dispense de
vienne n'a été après cette invention
alors j'avoue les armes bah oui mais tu
pourras pas d'imprimer une bombe
atomique fonctionnelle
pourquoi oui comme tu fais comment tu
fais le système qui fait la fission
comment tu la prime il y avait quand
même des limites à sa doit tu vois par
exemple imprimer une voiture une
typiquement c'est un peu un bon cas
d'école parce qu'un prime une voiture
qui va fonctionner qui va résister aux
forces de mouvements de le vent etc
l'aérodynamisme a priori tu peux pas
imprimer une voiture fonctionnelle en
plastique ça m'étonnerait que ça marche
les matériels vont quand même coûté un
peu de thunes toi ok alors j'ai imprimé
une armée de clones et de vaisseaux et
je conquiert la galaxie avait pensé à ça
quand apparaît une voiture thaler et tu
me dis que c'est pas parce qu'on a pris
mon voiture qui sera fonctionnelle en
fait c'est un gros des badges avec un
pote c'est qu'on disait imaginent demain
d'un prime en être humain tu vois pas ce
que c'est un être humain
en dehors de cette question qui se pose
imagine tu apprennes à un être humain
mais genre tout et tout et là tu vois
comme nous comme nous c'est beau
pourtant il vivra pas le moment où
l'imprimante s'arrête d'imprimer et que
tu as le corps qui hélas n'ont pas le ca
seras inerte il y aura le souffle de vie
toi y'a pas le truc qui fait que sa vie
en fait c'est le truc qui relance la
machine et ça on ne sait pas le faire
non oui non et ça c'est vous fais donc
pas ce que c'est et on c'est un gros
débat pour nous parce que du coup ça
entraîne à une autre question qui était
la question de l'âme
tu vois ou alors c'est pas forcément un
truc spirituel ou religieux ou quoi mais
ça peut prendre plein de formes l'âme
c'est un mot générique est ce qu'il ya
un truc en plus tu as qui fait que tout
ça ton reimer d'êtres humains mais c'est
tellement compliqué quoi enfin celle ci
à celle là aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
totalement impossible alors qu'à
imprimer un cyborg on sait déjà imprimé
du métal avec un des composants en fait
le mec est trop mal parti pour conquérir
la galaxie quoi bas sont aussi le c 17
qui marche pas tu arrives à les
entreposer dans un entrepôt les banques
d'affaires une morgue géante quoi par
contre toi non tu peux tu pourrais
imprime une armée de robots
par contre cela il fonctionnerait et là
ce serait flippant par confort dans un
méta dans une méta guerre tout le monde
imprimerie des cirrus north c'est
certain on refait son appart depuis
pirate bay il y aurait des plateformes
libres des changes de modèles 3d deux
parties génitales hadopi enverrait des
courriers pour le téléchargement illégal
du boul de kim kardashian
non je pense pas au caire alors là
encore une fois on est dans le mensonge
mais alors juste une précision par
rapport à ça il ya déjà un max de sites
de partage qui existent de boules de kim
kardashian
non mais tu honnêtement tu peux trouver
des tu peux trouver des sextoys de tout
tu peux trouver plein de trucs à rio il
ya un site encore une fois tu pourras le
met dans la description parce que même
si on n'est pas adepte de l'impression
3d c'est hyper cool max de la bannière
de youtube quoi
non mais non il n'y a aucune raison que
fabre f le site s'appelle singers et
c'est une plateforme de partage de
fichiers 3d le truc avec l'un est dedans
il ya aussi des trucs de cuba je suis
quasiment sûr que s'il table sextoys tu
trouve des trucs parce que c'est une
communauté hyper sk des boules de kim
kardashian je pense pas à me revanche le
mode et l'islam a dit kim kardashian en
3d soit pas de bien compliqué mais se
rend compte qu'on pourrait jusqu'à ne
sont sont enfin bref tu pourrais en plus
pour le scanner c'est hyper simple ce
qui est à moins de photos de son boule
que voilà mais en plus si tu peux
l'imprègne du tissu est tous abattu peu
à opprimer tu peux t'en faire un
oreiller énorme et c'est énorme mais ont
rayé il y aura des historiques
d'impression plutôt embarrassant ça
c'est sûr ça c'est évident ça c'est sûr
de toute façon un même sans fin je
descends l'impression 3d est un des
historiques ultra basse en quoi chez toi
il y aura des objets ultra étonnant du
voyage parce que tu vas pas considérer
baissier de juste pour voir vrai il y
avait les boules de kim kardashian moi
je vais pas le faire car la changer le
faire après tu lâches et toi tu as ton
papa chez toi là tu as une boule de kim
car ça va être bizarre jusqu'à la
conception de l'objet en fait en tout
cas toi ouais question question
subsidiaire
ouais s'il a aujourd'hui tu avais le
choix de pouvoir imprimer ce que tu veux
mais une seule fois
[ __ ] georges si je décide un prix mini
mini itx pareil on voit par exemple
hockey et mais est-ce que si je peux
imprimer une machine à voyager dans le
temps je peux le faire r - oui au moins
la vache jamais un truc de téléportation
mais moi j'allais dire un chat un super
tour est super chaque dose man tu as
l'occasion de créer un truc un chat âge
apprennent rien
un truc sur le faucon millenium et je me
bats rechapage en interstellaire jeu
moyen c'est la merde je sais pas avec
make merci d'être venus moi je t'en prie
mais bien là et merci d'être venus
du coup avec moi en copilote si tu veux
grand dormir il ya pas de ça marche la
preuve je prends le shift j'espère que
ça t'a plu c'était très cool c'est un
vrai plaisir et c'est très intéressant
j'ai appris plein de trucs ouais ouais
bah moi aussi j'ai appris des trucs en
avant pour de nouvelles aventures
1 et c'est parti ok mon gars répondez à
la question suivante dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo
seulement les commentaires de cette
vidéo t'imagines si hitler avait gagné
la seconde guerre mondiale ouais c'est
pas couple et ce sera un épisode avec
dave d'histoire bref je compte sur vous
là vous avez été énorme
il ya eu plus de 2000 commentaires le
travail de tri est vraiment dingue
jean marc système qui est derrière la
caméra pour sa part jean à chaque fois
enfin et bourgi les commentaires je suis
son bon bien quoi et on se revoit
bientôt love peace now
parce que si on s'y attend pas et si
jamais vous connaissez pas docteur
norman alors sa chaîne sa défense
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
pour ne rater aucune des prochaines
vidéos peut aussi me suivre sur facebook
twitter et snap chatte
un gros merci à dr nordmann si vous le
connaissez pas vous pouvez les tchèques
et son travail et nous on se retrouve
dans quelques jours pour une prochaine
vidéo